we can hardly wait for season 2 of The
Last of Us okay okay it's probably not
coming out until 2025 but we've got some
details about what this season May hold
and it's going to be a doozy if you're a
fan of The Last of Us video games that
the series was based on then you know
that season 1 of the hit HBO series
stuck fairly close to the source
material we can't be sure just yet that
the second season will do exactly the
same but it's safe to assume that the
story is headed in a similar Direction
at the very least if that is what
happens then this story is going some
pretty wild places and things are about
to get a lot darker according to writer
and Creator Craig Mason we were able to
map out all of season 2 and I also wrote
and submitted the script for the first
episode and sent it to HBO around 10:30
or 10:40 p.m. right before the midnight
that midnight the wga strike began Mason
has also said that the season has been
outlined in its entirety still the SAG
after strike means that the actors may
not know the broad Strokes of season 2
other than what they know from the game
and get ready because Major Spoilers at
least for the game are ahead cuz I I
know what in the second game and I'm I'm
nervous about being potentially without
pedo for a while The Last of Us second
video game installment brought on Plenty
of controversy so it's safe to say that
season two of the series may do the same
according to Mason though director Neil
dman and I will be adapting the story to
television as best we see fit it seems
likely that the main characters that are
crucial to the story line would be
portrayed but right now it's too early
for me to commit to anything in print
while we don't know exactly what season
2 holds for now we're taking a page from
Bella Ramsay's book it's not going to be
the same so I just have to like go into
it being like this is season 2 and I
loved season one but this is just going
to be different there's a time Jump
between the first and second game in the
first game like in season 1 Ellie is 14
years old and in the second game Ellie
is 19 years old which puts her closer to
20-year-old Bella Ramsay's age in real
life there hasn't been any firm
confirmation that there will or will not
be a time Jump between these two seasons
that said Mason does call this time jump
in the game important he also notes that
there's a primary shift in time but
there's also moments that you see that
are in between the events of the main
storyline when it comes to Parts one and
two of the game so it's safe to assume
that this is what we'll be seeing in
season 2 if this has you worried about
the nature of the time Jump though Mason
made one one thing clear we are not
doing House of the Dragon leaps those
were very significant leaps in age and
we don't have that so no recasting will
occur not on my watch it's difficult for
the series Creator to confirm or deny
which characters from The Last of Us
Part Two will appear in season 2 without
giving away some plot details so most
new characters have yet to be confirmed
that said controversial character Abby
has reportedly been cast the actor
however has yet to be revealed of course
Ramsey will be returning as Alli and
Pedro Pascal will be back as Joel it's
also been reported that Gabriel Luna
will return as Tommy and routina Wesley
will reprise the role of Maria now some
of us remember that in 2021 the issue of
a major pay gap between Pedro Pascal and
Bella Ramsey made headlines it was
reported that Pascal made
600,000 per episode while Bella made
just 70,000 there have been no reports
of what the Stars might earn next season
even so the pair has certainly gained
plenty of star power since season 1
began so it wouldn't be surprising if
they both made more money in season 2
the outcome of the SAG after strike is
also likely to affect the actor's pay
season 1 followed the Last of Us Part
One while season 2 is likely to follow
the Last of Us Part Two since the game
ends there there's been speculation that
the series second season will be its
last luckily though Craig Mason doesn't
think so his bet would be four though he
says you never know it can end up being
three or five but four seems like a good
number some Seasons because of the
stories we're telling will need to be
fewer episodes and some will need more
what those seasons will entail though
it's hard to predict one thing that is
certain season 2 is forthcoming when
it's coming however is still in question
as of now they have yet to begin filming
do you think there's a chance you'll be
filming the second season this year in
the year
2023 yes there is a chance yes well that
was back in Spring and now it seems
pretty unlikely that they'll start
filming in 2023 still the team te is
ready to go whenever the strike is
resolved I think we'll probably shoot
like end of this year beginning of next
and then it's a long it's like a year
filming so it'll be probably end of like
24 early 25 so until we get a firm
release date we'll just have to be
patient and maybe play the games in the
meantime are you excited for season 2
what are you most hoping to see let's
discuss it in the comments and for more
videos like this one be sure to like And
subscribe do the
things